a la cual ha apostado siempre a tres
pilares fundamentales en su desarrollo
la la la salud la educación y el
desarrollo técnico científico y muy
basado en las vacunas de ahora que no me
sorprende que cuba en este momento está
desarrollando una vacuna contra la cop10
y nueve ya tienen la experiencia de la
una contra meningococo la hepatitis b y
otras vacunas como el morfi los
influencia que han sido muy exitosos en
el control de estas enfermedades pero
también el país espera producir 100
millones de dosis de inocular a sus 11
millones de habitantes y además exportar
el resto a las naciones de las regiones
son realmente realistas estos planes que
tiene el gobierno cubano
tiene la capacidad instalada en el
centro de ingeniería genética y en el
instituto carlos finlay de producir
estas vacunas yo conozco personalmente
este desarrollo en 1990 92 hicimos un
estudio cuando yo estaba en colombia con
conciencia sobre los avances y el modelo
cubano de ciencia y tecnología y yo creo
que tiene la capacidad instalada para
hacerlo y nuevamente cuando los cubanos
deciden que esto es una prioridad en
salud pública así lo lo hacen de manera
que confíen que en que lo van a hacer
sin los resultados de la fase 3 muestran
realmente la eficacia de las vacunas
pues justamente esa es la siguiente
pregunta estamos hablando por ahora de
la soberana 2 y de la abdalá qué pasa
con las otras dos candidatas a vacunas y
con la publicación justamente los
estudios clínicos de los cuatro fármacos
que aún no se han dado a conocer
este es un punto muy importante y los
técnicos y los científicos cual nos
tienen que publicar en revistas
internacionales sus resultados para
tener una validez y una revisión de sus
padres
es la única manera como va a ser
aceptada esta vacuna por fuera de cuba y
se hace yo lo utilicen
internamente pero para exportación y
para el mundo entero necesitan publicar
estos resultados que aún no se han visto
principio de fase 1 o 2 en publicaciones
internacionales bueno también así como
se conoce a cuba por su diplomacia
médica se sabe que es un país que
depende en gran medida del turismo se ha
hablado de la posibilidad que los
antídotos o estos o fármacos sean
ofrecidos también los turistas qué opina
usted de esta posibilidad y que
representaría entonces para la
vacunación en américa latina
cuba ha sido tradicionalmente un país
que hace el turismo de salud y ha sido
también incorporada en sus planes
tampoco me sorprende que le tomen a la
vacunación como una una oportunidad de
incrementar el turismo en salud pero
nuevamente todo todo se basa en mirar
cuáles son los resultados de la eficacia
y la seguridad de las vacunas
eso es el tema más importante si sin
estas publicaciones y sin estos
resultados pues ninguno de sus planes de
la ciencia cubana va a poder avanzar